all right
yeah okay let's get started I'm going to
introduce the speaker for the rest of
the day and the next talk is going to be
by mu prowl and Nupur is now a postdoc
in Georgia Tech working with Santosh
before that he actually completed his
ph.d math with Daniel Stillman in Yale
University working without words today
is going to talk about robust estimation
mean and covariance that's just thank
you okay so before talking about robust
statistics let's consider a classical
estimation problem suppose they're given
samples from a 1d distribution say 1d
Gaussian and we want to estimate its
mean and variance can we do it the
answer is yes we can use sample mean and
sample variance and this this is the
maximum likelihood estimator for for
this problem and back probably a century
back Fisher proved that maximum
likelihood estimators are optimal in a
certain specific sense later
Tukey asked what if there is error in
the model this resulted in a whole field
called robust statistics there are many
books now written in this field and the
central question studied can be
summarized as what estimate how do
estimators do well in a neighborhood of
the model
so consider the 1d example again suppose
we have gaussian samples but now
corrupted by some noise can we
accurately estimate mean and variance
before answering that we need to
constrain the noise somehow there are
many ways to do this one natural way is
we let the adverse we let an adversary
add ETA fraction of points this was
initially suggested by huber and also
studied in robust statistics literature
more precisely suppose we have m points
1 minus ETA fraction are independently
sampled from an underlying distribution
and ETA fraction of them are chosen by
an adversary adversary can look at the
samples from the distribution before
choosing the points which is a slight
strengthening of Huber's contamination
model and now we would want to estimate
mean and covariance for this talk when I
mean what I mean by estimating mean and
Cohen's is we want to estimate a mu hat
which is close to MU into norm and a
sigma hat which is close to true Sigma
the covariance matrix in the Frobenius
norm
before going into the details just some
applications talk about some
applications principal component
analysis is a widely used tool for
various learning tasks like clustering
dimensionality reduction in learning
Gaussian in mixture models independent
component analysis where usually people
compute the top k principal components
where K is a constant and project on to
project the data onto this space but
even if there are two K corrupted points
the top K principal components can be
completely completely off so we would
like to estimate the covariance matrix
in the presence of noise coming back to
the 1d 1d case 1d Gaussian does
empirical mean the sample mean and
variance work in this case just if you
think for a bit you can convince
yourself that this will fail badly even
if you have one noise point place far
away from the true mean the sample mean
can be arbitrarily bad but in this case
there is an easy fix if you look at
median that's a good estimator of the
mean in the presence of noise and you
can show that this is optimal and for
the variance you can use what's called
median absolute deviation which is the
median of the distances of points from
the median
so down the real question that we'll
address in this talk is what what about
in higher dimensions there have been
several approaches suggested in robust
statistics literature and most of them
are motivated by higher generalizations
of median to higher dimensions so I'll
give a table in the next slide so for
the rest of the talk M will denote the
number of samples and the dimension of
the data and eta is the fraction of the
noise so here is a list of approaches
that have been studied and the key thing
to note here is either the error has a
polynomial factor in the dimension or
the estimator is np-hard to compute in
general or it's exponential time to
compute in general so two key median was
has optimal performance it is a
generalization of median to higher
dimension but it's hard to compute in
general and geometric median which is
which has an efficient algorithm has a
square root and square root dependence
on the dimension so then the question is
is this all we can do this roba
statistics has existed for many decades
and until the like an ear back this this
was the kind of status where either the
we have an airy computationally
expensive algorithm or a polynomial
dependence on the dimension in the error
guarantee
so thankfully we have an answer like
which it need not be the case where
there are now efficient algorithms which
have a good added guarantees and let me
state the results here so I should say
that this appeared in Fox 2016 along
with Ilyas and his quarters and another
paper appeared written by Ilyas and
quarters and since then there has been a
lot of work in this and I won't be
talking about them but you'll see many
of that in the next talk so we would
need the algorithm will work we need
some assumption on the distribution and
the assumption the distribution for us
need has to satisfy what's called
bounded fourth moment that is in any
direction the fourth moment should be at
most see four times the second moment
square the error guarantees can be
parameters in terms of c4
but for this talk LSE mc4 is some
constant and many general classes of
distributions satisfy this property if a
distribution has finite fourth moment
then this is obviously true and sub
Gaussian sub-exponential and many other
distributions satisfy this
so here's the main result so if we know
the covariance matrix and we want to
estimate the mean robustly then we can
compute a mu hat such that it's at most
e to power 3/4 times Sigma square root
login away so the thing to focus on is
that the dependence on the dimension is
square root login instead of the usual
square root N and we have a lower bound
of e to power three-fourths Sigma in in
this case so I should say say that all
the results I'll state will be with high
probability so it will hold with one
minus one over poly n probability and in
the Oh
also there's a another stronger noise
model that people consider where an
adversary can delete some points and add
some noise points and even in this case
the results hold though when we wrote
the paper we were not looking at that
model and in the case of unknown
covariance the dependence on ETA is like
ETA square root ETA instead of heat up
our 3/4 otherwise the dimensional
dependence is still square root login
and in both these cases the sample
complexity is nearly linear which is n
almost n log square and overeater square
and before going into the next slide I
should point out that in the case the
distribution is Gaussian then we can
improve this ETA power 3/4 to ETA and I
will catch a proof of that later on and
if you want to estimate the covariance
we use the essentially the same
algorithm as estimating the mean a main
thing to note is that if say the mean is
0 then covariance is expectation of XX
transpose now if we so that's the mean
of XX transpose so if we write down xx
transpose as a vector and apply the mean
estimation algorithm then we can get
this guarantee which is we can infer
vinius norm get square root eta log n to
norm of the covariance matrix and we'll
since we are applying the mean
estimation algorithm to second-order
objects XS transpose will need the
slightly stronger condition which is 8
moments we need bounded eight moments
and a twice independence so for the rest
of the talk I will focus on mean
estimation algorithm and also I will
assume the underlying distribution is
Gaussian with noun covariance before
jumping into the gaussian case I just
want to point out that in the case of
fourth bounded fourth moment even in one
dimension it's a median doesn't work so
this here is a simple distribution with
mean zero to point it's concentrated on
just two points even without noise the
median doesn't work if we have odd
number of samples but there is a simple
fix can compute the smaller and
intervals of length smallest interval
which contains 1 minus theta fraction of
the points and compute the sample mean
and that will be a we can show that as a
good estimator
and though the algorithm that I'll state
in the remaining slides will be for
Gaussian with this is the main switch
that one has to do to make it work for
the general distributions so two
questions one is ETA is known for your
ETA is we can assume Mita is known but
it's not necessarily we can make it work
like we can do a binary search kind of
site your error guarantee seems from
what about this even comment on the
sample complexity there it seems like
formal estimation does M log square n by
ETA square yeah after log upload log
factors even if you don't have any noise
that would be kind of T you just squared
because in later slide elite about four
by three oh yeah so because we give a
weaker guarantee for the unknown
covariance case so we can get away with
it apart for four or three instead of
ETA square
the moment so find the smallest interval
and considered all the points that lie
inside this interval and compute the
sample mean or the sample variance that
will be the estimators
so in higher dimension that as we as I
alluded to before there have been many
that can there are many generalizations
of median here are to coordinate wise
median where you look at n coordinate
directions and compute the median in
each of them that gives you a point in n
dimension or geometric median which is
minimizing l2 distances both of this can
be shown to have a square root n
dependence on the dimension in
coordinate wise median it is easy to
show that this H it achieves square root
n by just 1d argument because in each
each coordinate direction we incur an
error of ETA Sigma and since there are n
direction will have a square root n
dependence so it's not just smaller so
both both of this will achieve achieve
this bound it's not just the lowered one
and the bad case for both of them is
this like where this is say gaussian
points that are 1 minus ETA fraction r
this blue gaussian points and if you
place all the noise points on a diagonal
diagonally and that will be the worst
case configuration that will be a worst
case configuration for both the
geometric median and coordinate phase
median
so before going into the algorithm let's
consider an easy case in the higher
dimension suppose we are given the mean
shift direction the mean shift Direction
is the is the difference is the
direction from the true mean the
Gaussian mean to the sample mean sample
mean has is has this noise points though
it can be way off so this is the mean
shift direction suppose we are given
this direction then this is an easy
problem essentially we can reduce it to
N 1 a 1d dime a 1d problem if we project
all the points on to the N minus 1
dimensional space perpendicular to this
mean shift direction we note that there
is no mean shift in this space so we can
just compute the sample mean as the
estimator and remaining is just one
dimensional problem so and in 1d
everything is easy so so overall will
incur an error of ETA Sigma so if we
know this direction then the problem is
easy and one can ask if the top
principal component gives this direction
but as we have seen before even two
points appropriately placed will
completely destroy the top principal
component so that won't work
so let's I'll give them main algorithm
so it alternates between two two kinds
of steps one is a weak outlier removal
step things that are like really far
away from the gaussian points you can
throw them away and then you project
onto the top n over two principal
components and recurs in the bottom n or
two principal components we can estimate
the mean by just the sample mean going
over the algorithm more slowly say this
this is our point configuration the blue
points are gaussian and the red points
are the noise points
we consider a big enough ball around the
big enough ball so that we preserve all
the gaussian points so all the gaussian
points are concentrated around 2 Sigma
square root n from the true mean so it's
really concentrated and things that I
say far away is probably bigger than a
bigger than 10 Sigma square root anyway
just throw them away throw them out and
how can we do this we can just compute
the coordinate wise median we know it's
good up to square root n factor and that
won't hurt us for this step so look at
the coordinate wise median consider a
ball of say radius 10 Sigma square root
n away 10 Sigma square root n radius and
throw away all the points outside it
okay so then we need to identify a good
subspace what what I mean by a good
subspace is a very high dimensional
subspace where the sample mean coincides
or has is very close to the true mean
and we can do that by computing the
covariance matrix and computing the
bottom n over two principal components
the space spanned by that is a good
subspace you can show that the sample
mean is close to the true mean so we
compute the sample mean in the bottom
no.2 space and in the top and outer
space we just recurs we repeat the whole
process so thing to notice that when we
recurse now the dimension has reduced by
a factor of two so when we do the
outlier removal step in the next
iteration the ball has shrunk because
the radius of the ball is like square
root n now it will be square root n over
two so we'll have tighter and tighter
apply em all as we progressed so this
here is just going over the algorithm
again we have discussion points and
noise points and we consider a big
enough ball throw away all the noise
points outside it and then compute a
good
good subspace the thing the property
that will show like show is that if this
is the mean shift vector which is the
vector connecting the true mean and the
sample mean it's projection onto the
sorry bottom no.2 space is small okay so
example mean coins is very close to the
true mean I will sketch I can sketch
there is a proof as well you take two
three slides so first we will write down
what the covariance matrix is in terms
of the Gaussian part and the noise part
so here Sigma s is the sample covariance
matrix we can write it as a sum of
Gaussian covariance matrix and the noise
covariance matrix just the cohens matrix
of the noise points and rank one rank
one term coming from the difference in
the mean
so what the outlier remote step gives us
is a way to bound the trace of the noise
points which in turn lets us control the
no.2 earth eigenvalue of the sample
covariance matrix so this this is the
this is just the gaussian covariance
part so if you call the rim all the
remaining terms as matrix a the outlier
removal step lets us control the trace
of a by ETA Sigma square N and by a
standard result in matrix perturbation
you can show that the n node is called
vales inequality a node to at eigen
value of the sample covariance matrix is
the top eigenvalue of the gaussian part
which is 1 minus theta Sigma square plus
the no2 at eigen value of this
perturbation and because we have a
control on the trace we can say that the
no2 at eigen value of the sample
covariance matrix is very close to that
of the Gaussian markets just 1 plus
order ETA if you just look at the
gaussian part is 1 minus theta so we
have just sawed off by order ETA Sigma
square so how can we control the trace
essentially the point is that since the
outlet after the outlier removal step
every point is within a distance of
Sigma square root n away from each other
so that essentially says that if you
have a set of points that are all within
a distance L from each other then the
trace of the covariance matrix will be L
times n applying it to this will give us
the trace of the covariance matrix Sigma
n will be just Sigma square n it's not L
tension it's just L so that so we can
control the trace of ETA Sigma
n by this quantity and the same applies
for the rank one matrix which is Delta
Delta transpose the second step is
essentially that once we have a control
over the no.2 Tigan value the projection
of the mean shift vector should be small
and why is that if so this is the mean
shift vector and look at its projection
on the bottom in order to space then the
Rayleigh quotient of this should be
small because no.2 tige we have a bound
upper bound on the N or two orthogonal U
so this is essentially the argument so
if we look at the unit vector along the
projection of the mean shift vector then
the Rayleigh quotient which is this the
W transpose Sigma SW can be bounded by
the no2 at eigenvalue and then it's so
then we just argue that this can't be
too big because if this Delta was too
big then it will imply that the no2 at
eigenvalue also has to be big so what we
can show is that the projection of the
mean shift vector onto the bottom n Otto
space is ETA square Sigma square so just
to note this is an N or two dimensional
space and we are incurring an error
which is independent of the dimension so
this is where we reduce the dimensional
dependence and where we get this square
root login is because we recurse this
algorithm log n times so each time we
have an N or two dimensional space where
there is no dimensional dependence but
we have to add login of this so
combining that will give us ETA square
Sigma square login
so it's a pretty simple algorithm to
code this is essentially the code in
MATLAB
there is one outlier removal routine
that's missing here but it's like
another half a slide and one might
wonder how it does in practice so here
is a here is a plot where we plotted the
geometric median geometric median and so
this is the geometric median which is
growing with the dimension so the
dimension goes up to 2000 here and blue
is the performance of the algorithm and
the last one yellow one is just the
sample mean where since we know what the
noise points are we just throw away all
the noise points and just compute the
sample mean in fact I can show a demo
yeah so this is like 10% yeah this is
the yeah both are Gaussian yeah Cerreta
Cal question yeah so here is a demo for
just the mean estimation algorithm here
again so the this is the geometric
median that's being computed and the
dimensions go from like two hundred four
hundred eight hundred and thousand six
hundred and the output of the algorithm
is this blue line which pretty much
stays constant we don't even see this
square root log at the project squared
login is too hard to see anyway but it
looks flat and the final the this is the
sample mean the true sample mean
this one has like 10 times the dimension
yeah this this is the this is the noise
points had another Gaussian but with a
different mean but yeah but we tried
this with many different noise
distributions in fact centers gave it as
an assignment to students to come up
with different noise distributions and
they all thought with the same so ok so
this one and also let me show the
over the estimation
so the thing to I want to point out is
this for covariance estimation we
actually had to compute this huge
matrices so if the problem is D
dimension we compute these vectors which
is d square and we compute the
covariance of this D square dimensional
object so it's like the matrices here
are like d square cross d square so the
experiments I am showing you will go
only up until 60 that something would be
very good to get rid of and there is a
case where we can get rid of so this was
also in the paper so if we if the
problem was just to estimate the 2 norm
of the covariance matrix then we don't
need to construct this d square cross d
square objects so an algorithm that we
had I won't go into detail here is just
is the following for estimating the 2
norm of the covariance matrix robustly
is you compute the sample covariance
matrix and the top principal component
and so say this is the top principal
component and we can estimate the
variance also in this direction because
it is a 1d problem we can just project
onto 1d we can estimate the variance
accurately and if they if they are close
to each other we just output we are done
if they differ by a lot then we apply a
threshold to hyperplanes and throw away
all the points outside it and then we
repeat so we compute the sample
covariance matrix again and top
principal component N and we can show
that this converges in order dimension
iterations and the key thing that I want
to point out is that this construct only
D Square D cross D covariance matrices
though we are estimating something about
the second order of teleca's to norm of
the covariance matrix not just me
so it will be this is the threshold
window so just to summarize we give an
algorithm for estimating mean and
covariance robustly and estimating
covariance matrix robustly we'll have
many applications in the paper which
show how it can be used for doing
independent component analysis when
there are arbitrary noise a small
fraction of arbitrary noise and for mean
estimation it requires only nearly
linear number of samples and you can
find the code here and there are many
köppen questions here one is can we
match the lower bounds in this case of
unknown covariance matrix so there was a
gap of e to power 3/4 versus square root
ETA can we close that gap also the
square root login factor and can we give
a better algorithm for covariance
estimation in fact better algorithm for
either mean or covariance but at least
for mean estimation we can easily go up
to diamond mm dimension equal to mm
which is not the case for covariance
estimation and we can ask similar
questions for many other learning
problems where you have a generative
model for generating the data what if
some fraction is chosen by like some
fraction is outlier when is the when is
can you make the algorithm more robust
to such noise thank you
[Applause]
very nice talk I usually in practice you
don't know that the conference is yeah
so I so we have that in the paper so we
don't need to know the covariance matrix
if we know the covariance matrix we can
reduce it to a spherical case so when we
don't know the covariance matrix we get
a weaker bond well which is ETA power
square root ETA instead of e to power
3/4 and the main change the algorithm is
essentially same the main change is how
do we determine this ball the radius of
the ball that we use for outlier removal
in this case in the spherical case we
can just estimate the variance in one
direction and use that as the radius so
in the non spherical case we can
estimate the variance in n orthogonal
direction each is a 1d problem and look
that gives an estimate for the trace and
we'll use stress as the estimate for the
radius of the ball and the rest of the
algorithm will remain the same condition
number of the covariance it doesn't but
the error guarantee will be as I stated
the error guarantee everything is
nothing depends on the condition number
but you can hope to get stronger error
guarantees depending on the matrix and
you probably see that in the next talk
when yeah
is your estimate of the covalent which
is guaranteed to be volumes under it is
not guaranteed to be positive definite
we can project onto the positive
semi-definite coin yeah it will because
the Frobenius norm will just you can
show it it just gets better
yeah so for ETA we can try so I should
probably answer that offline because I
haven't really wrote it down anywhere
yes I think that is true so this will
this will as this essentially says that
you can compute - comedian approximately
in this kind of average case sense so -
comedian I choose this error guarantee
and and that has to be like close to the
true mean and we show that the our
estimator also is close to the true mean
so that shows the it's an approximation
to the - comedian but there might be I
don't know of a way to directly compute
the - comedian as in probably not have a
flicker statement
there's no more
[Applause]